dr sadler is here to present the
analytic continental bug
um it's probably easier actually to say
what he hasn't done
than what he has done um but obviously
the most important
is that we have a youtube star amongst
us
um
but anyway
so
he's also the president and co-founder
of reason io
um he is doing an entire video series
bravely
trudging through the phenomenology of
spirit through hegel and explaining it
um
let's see
here his phd from southern illinois
university in 2002
tall all over the east coast but
he had an epiphany when he was at
mayor's college that
he must
move to the philosophical utopia that is
wisconsin and he is
kindly blown down air force
um
[Music]
i think that's all i got
that sounds good
[Applause]
yeah well
i've never heard wisconsin described as
a philosophical utopia but it is pretty
great to be back there that's where i'm
from originally so you know
i think i was ready to leave in my 20s
and now i'm ready to be back in my 40s
so i was asked to talk about the
analytic continental divide as a general
topic and what what analytics and
continental philosophers
can learn from each other
more specifically and i do intend to
talk about that
but i think i should probably lay my
cards on the table from the beginning i
don't have a dog in the fight
i'm neither an analytic nor a
continental although i do work on some
some figures in continental philosophy
i'm more of a historian of philosophy
so i do a lot of my work on historical
figures
and
i look at things in a historical way so
i'm going to do some talking about
that
more towards the end
[Music]
and
what i'm going to suggest is that one of
the things many philosophers who
identify as analytics or continentals
could learn
although not so much just from each
other is that there's a much vaster and
richer world of philosophical approaches
out there that they can draw upon
so what i was thinking i would do is is
uh lecture for about 90 minutes or so
have
30 minutes of q a at the end when i say
lecture i don't mean that i'm just going
to talk straight for 90 minutes which i
think would be rather boring and
tiresome
but we'll you know i'll raise some
points and i'm sure we'll have some
questions and maybe we'll you know take
a break every so often when we need to
for general discussion um so feel free
to ask questions at any time
if you take if you take me off course
i'm pretty good at getting back on
course
so don't don't worry about that
um the structure of the the talk what i
wanted to do first is actually talk
about
and i've created a handout to sort of
launching point for this talk about the
way in which
we tend to think about this divide and
some of the
some of the ways that analytic
philosophers think about continental
philosophers and vice versa or at least
the way they're represented
and
then i want to talk about my my own uh
background in this
which is a bit unusual
um
and how i that led me to what this focus
on the divide leaves out
and then i want to talk about how we
might
define or characterize different kinds
of philosophy in general not just
analytic and continental but but other
movements as well then we'll focus in on
trying to answer the question which we
won't actually completely do what is
analytic philosophy we'll do that for
for continental philosophy
then we'll talk about the notion in the
history and and really the the ongoing
reality of a divide
along with a few examples of people who
bridge or talk across that divide
and i'd like to finish by talking about
what else there there is for
oh what analytic and continental
philosophers have to learn from each
other we'll talk quite a bit about that
but i also want to talk about what they
can learn from other philosophies
and i'm going to put in a plug for
thinking about philosophy in a more
historically oriented way which we often
associate with continentals but i don't
think continentals on the whole actually
do a very good job at that
i think they're very selective in their
their use
of history some of them not not all of
them so
if we think about
you know
one of the things people typically say
you can look at this at this chart and
see whether you think this is a fair
representation of how analytic
philosophy and continental philosophy
get contrasted
in your own experience
in the literature that's out there is
quite vast literature out there
comparing analytic and continental
philosophy it's something that will crop
up every so often in blog columns
in the new york times in part because it
seems to be a perennial
interest
um i mean what do you guys think is this
fairly accurate depiction
of what's good and also perhaps what's
what's uh
maybe blind spots or or
problems with the two different modes of
doing philosophy
what did you say i mean most of you are
analytically trained right
is there anybody in here who would
say that they're continentally trained
where that was the main focus
no okay so one person so
um so it's primarily analytics and and
uh
what they would say about continentals
does this
just work
i mean you know
continental philosophy you know we know
that it's coming from the continent that
one's i think pretty uncontroversial
ideals of critique at least they use
that word quite a lot subjectivity
imagination
as opposed to
sort of other ideals of clarity
objectivity rationality rationality is
even a dirty word among some continental
philosophers
more aligned with the humanities would
you agree that's that's
that's true
it's interesting if you think about the
social sciences
so we can say that analytic philosophy
traditionally historically has been
associated more with the natural
sciences and mathematics
the social sciences are in a
interesting spot where
some of the some of their practitioners
have much more in common with the
analytic philosophy some much more with
continental philosophy
what do you think about the you know
criticized as incomprehensible
relativist trendy or fattish
obscure polemical poetic and so on
say that's
accurate as far as like what they get
criticized for
yeah what about the one for analytics
criticized as a historical
myopic superficial imperialistic is a
popular one for a while
unimaginative
have you heard these these
complaints
okay so so we we have a more or less
agreed-upon starting point
and we'll come back to that so now my
own background
i had a
a strange
introduction to all this stuff in part
because i didn't go to a place that was
primarily analytic or primarily
continental either for my my
undergraduate or my graduate studies
and my undergraduate they you know i
wouldn't
i wouldn't highly recommend it i don't
know what it's like now these days but
if it's like what i had i don't think i
would recommend it for undergraduates to
study philosophy because they thought
that
there were really three kinds of
philosophy living at the time those were
analytic philosophy which seemed to be
dying out we're talking about like the
mid 90s here so um clearly it wasn't
dying out
but that was their view existentialism
so it wasn't all continental philosophy
just existentialism
and process philosophy those were the
three main going concerns
i managed to get introduced to
continental philosophy by a fluke there
was a japanese student in my modern
philosophy class
who wrote a 60-page paper for the the
class
and in which
in which she incorporated all sorts of
contemporary continental theory uh
including you know the wooze and derrida
and you know bhaktine and he had these
books and he felt that his english
wasn't good enough to present the paper
and he wanted me to do it so he just
gave me these books and said why don't
you read these and this will help you
present them i didn't give the books
back
and i kept them on my shelf and then i
started reading them and i thought it
was interesting stuff
i also majored in mathematics
while i was an undergraduate and so i
did a lot of work in
the intersections between philosophy and
mathematics
specifically in logic foundations of
i was getting very interested in in
philosophy of language at the time and
so i was reading a lot of stuff in
analytic journals
totally discouraged by my professors
i would just go to the library and kind
of read around stuff that looked
interesting getting you know just a
smattering of stuff then i went to
graduate school and i went like joseph
said i went to southern illinois
university
and southern illinois is a particularly
interesting place in that it's a
pluralistic department so
um they have representatives of analytic
philosophy there they have
representatives of continental
philosophy and then what they're really
known for is american philosophy
classical american philosophy including
but not exclusively pragmatism they have
the john dewey center there
i actually got kind of turned off on
dewey because i heard about him so much
at that place
but it was great because we would have
you know every class there were
you know if it was a primarily analytic
class it'd be mostly the analytics
students there but there'd be a
smattering of other people so you'd
always get challenges
coming in you needed to speak each
other's language at least to some degree
and
the relations were not always cordial
as a matter of fact there was a history
at one time of some pretty tough uh
battles between them but it was it was
good to see i also got interested in the
history philosophy there
not because siu had a strength in that
in the philosophy department
but because i was studying languages and
so i did my my plato and my aristotle in
graduate school with the classics
department you know just reading them in
in greek and i
you know got interested in um anselm and
aquinas through through working on my
latin
um
and that that led me into to taking more
and more historically oriented
perspective
the philosophy departments that i've
worked in and organizations and
conferences also tend to be pluralists
as well and so there'd be some analytics
some continentals and then a whole bunch
of other people that that didn't fall
into that spectrum and so when when i
think of the the you know the divide
i've always seen it as a little bit
arbitrary
um
and you know it got me interested why
why is this the case i know i never
really gave it an awful lot of thought
until joseph told me he wanted me to
talk about it
uh and then since then i've been doing a
lot of reading
in the literature
about that divide and there is a huge
literature out there
um
in general what i can say is is this
that it is something that does exist but
it represents a kind of limited
or limiting view on on philosophy um
that that can can interfere with
um
you know getting getting a good grasp of
some other areas in philosophy that one
might miss and i've got a couple
analogies here it's sort of like if we
were i'm a big metal head and so those
of you who are into that genre can
probably grasp this analogy it would be
like if um in discussing heavy metal one
claim that really all contemporary metal
is either in the black or death metal
range or as a form of alternative metal
so there's no
classic metal
that's not really metal there's no you
know thrash there's no power metal
there's no glam there's no nothing it's
just those those are really all the the
main going concern
another perhaps better
metaphor would be like a long-standing
feud
a feud in which most of the current
feuders
don't really know how the feud got
started
got continued got renewed and they don't
really know all that well many of the
side that they identify with they know
some of them very very well
but the rest of it they're a bit hazy on
and they know that those other guys over
there are bad or you know
doing something
wrong but they're not they they have
some ideas of what it is they've been
told what it is
but there's a lot of haziness about it
you might say and some rather global
judgments and assumptions usually based
on hearsay or a few experiences
because you know if you if you want to
have a bad impression of
of continental philosophers it's not
hard to find just go to spep and and
wander around into a few you know
sessions and you're gonna hear some some
you know
goofy nonsense
um
but that's not the whole of it right you
can't judge from those few experiences
and so it is sort of like like a
long-standing feud
there's
there's limits to what we can do with
the neologies but
what have we left out
what what doesn't fit into this this
divide
well most of the main traditions or
schools or movements of western
philosophy and ancient uh medieval and
modern philosophy
don't fit neatly into it there's there's
analytic readings of history of
philosophy and there's continental
readings but that's not quite the same
thing as actually you know
reading plato for for plato's
own sakes or reading plato in light of
plato
there's also non-western philosophy a
huge huge world out there on that and
comparative philosophy and some of that
does get done by analytics and by
continentals but
not not that much classical american
philosophy doesn't fit into this divide
um where do pragmatists fit
you know just to pick one of the uh the
groups
uh african-american philosophy or
africana philosophy uh
changes uh names from from time to time
in place to place um feminist philosophy
there are analytic feminist feminists
there are continental feminists there
there are some who say that um it's a
distinct
tradition of its own um that probably
does you know merit being taken
seriously
um philosophy is a way of life
maybe some people you know in the
academic philosophy think that's just
sort of you know pandering but it's it's
it's interesting that it's out there and
that it's uh
got quite a lot of traction
um
so these are all worth you know thinking
about where they fit in here they
they're not in the divide
um
how do they
inform any of that
um so
let's then talk about um
how we would
well let's call it and not say to define
philosophy but the characterize
philosophy
so
when you look at your philosophy
textbooks or you know those of you who
teach when you teach your intro class or
probably a lot of your other classes one
of the things you have to do
is say well what is philosophy for the
people who have that as a question right
that's a very difficult thing to do
isn't it
and there's reasons i think good reasons
why why it's difficult and why we're not
often happy with what we say
some of the reasons you have to do with
the very nature of philosophy
and we can understand philosophy not
just as
say an activity but also as a
disciplinary field and as a body of
literature as all three of these
intersecting with each other um
and as a side note this this problem of
adequately defining philosophy and that
distinction that i just made between
three different ways of looking at
philosophy that came up in something
i've done a lot of work on
this uh
rather obscure debate that took place in
france in the 1930s
about the the possibility or nature of
christian philosophy
um they ended up writing a book about it
mostly of translations
and they they hashed out these same
issues though what is philosophy
and it was interesting to see that they
they weren't on the same page it was
good for them to have to try to clarify
to each other what exactly is philosophy
and what isn't philosophy but they never
achieved a consensus and if they didn't
achieve a consensus in that small
community
we're not going to achieve a
overall consensus in in the entire
philosophical community it's it's going
to be a perennial issue
um some of those reasons on the one hand
there's a genuine question that's that's
what we can call an outward facing one
it would be nice if we could
give some sort of characterization of
philosophy to people who were asking us
from the outside hey what are you doing
um
that would that would be good and then
there's an inward facing question we're
ourselves interested in what are we
doing uh when we when we uh
try to
pause from from you know
this particular activity or that
particular activity
and um
nearly any way of describing philosophy
ends up looking like a description from
some particular point of view
that try it out you know and see whether
you're not bringing in some assumptions
uh about philosophy coming from some
particular way of doing philosophy and
that that's you know i'm not saying
that's a terrible thing
it's just uh one of the conditions that
we we work under
um
is also in the past maybe not so much in
the present but in the past have what we
can call a uh
you might call it totalizing
uh ambition
it and i don't mean this in a pejorative
sense it tried to extend itself to
everything
you know to have a you know you might
say a theory of everything right uh or
at least some systematic conception of
it now in you know in the 20th century
we've seen some efforts to try to prune
philosophy down to something more
manageable
those all presume that that philosophy
first of all is able to do that but even
when you prune stuff away you're still
taking a stance on what you're pruning
away so there's still kind of a
totalizing a thing to it which you know
makes it difficult to define as well
um not only that if we if we really
engage the past of philosophy you know
the the great thinkers that we you guys
have those pictures up in the hallway
for example
and that's just a few of them and we
don't just sort of shoehorn them
uh
into
reductive categories but we you know we
really look through them we find a
multiplicity of ways in which philosophy
has been done and structured and
understood even if we just look at the
ancient period
you know the the platonus had a pretty
different conception of philosophy
in certain respects than did say the
epicureans or the you know the when
plato's academy goes skeptic
um they have a somewhat different
conception as well
so all that said um
[Music]
what about these two important ways of
doing philosophy in the present
um does that mean that we it's hopeless
we can't say anything about them well
that would be that would be
extraordinarily strange wouldn't it
uh because we we know there is something
distinctive to analytic philosophy and
presumably there's something distinctive
to continental philosophy
so how might we go about
characterizing them and differentiating
them like this so one thing we could do
is focus on
national or cultural or linguistic
spheres that that's one thing
we can also focus on canons of
literature you know who should be read
we can focus on what other disciplines
are typically engaged
or become allies
we can focus on characteristic methods
that are employed including attitudes
towards arguments and tests
and we can also focus in on ideals or
aims for philosophy itself
this is not an exclusive an exhaustive
list there's other things i think we
could do as well but i think that's
that's quite a lot to work with already
so i want to set these out and then
discuss why although initially promising
um in our present time particularly in
our present time we're not really
adequate for
telling us what analytic and continental
philosophy are
although they may be all that we have
um
so start with the easiest national and
linguistic spheres where is the analytic
philosophy done
primarily there's some people doing it
in france by the way and germany
the words are primarily done
english-speaking
yeah the anglo-sphere we can call it
where else there's there's another area
where
you find it
where it's the predominant way of doing
philosophy
yeah why is that isn't that a weird
thing or shouldn't they go with the rest
of the europeans
but culturally they've been sort of in
the orbit for a while and you know
english is a very common second language
so there's you know there's that
continental philosophy you know
european continent of course so
france germany italy spain um but it's
also a big concern in south america
um
you know it's hard to to say exactly
where else
because you can find it all around the
world there's also massive colonies here
you know there are there are continental
departments
here as well
now it's good to note that different
areas did develop different
philosophical approaches and literatures
but that's really more of a starting
point it doesn't answer any questions
for us i think
you know we can point to like perhaps
sociological features of french culture
as opposed to english culture but i
don't i don't know that we get that much
mileage
out of that
and it's important to note that we're
having this conversation at all
because presumably some analytic
philosophers would like to know what
they can learn from continental
philosophers not just because they're
they're over there in europe but because
you can find them here uh at florida or
duquesne or um you know where else would
we go there's a lot of other
pockets
where you can you can find people doing
it so you would be another other place
as well
um what about canons of literature
can we identify analytic philosophy or
continental philosophy with who they
they read
well think about why a canon is
important
you know or you might say how is a canon
it tells you whose ideas
are or approaches or systems are worth
looking into look worth paying attention
to worth studying
um
maybe also you know reacting to
who do you need to take seriously as an
adversary and who can you just totally
dismiss
who should he borrow from
um i'm going to return to this issue of
canon later but
i think it's not a particularly
promising one in the present i think it
could have been useful around 1960
for characterizing continental and
analytic philosophy or maybe even you
know 1980 i don't think it's as useful
now and i'll tell you why in just just a
bit
um maybe another way we can think about
it is how does philosophy situate itself
in relation to other disciplines
you know because philosophy doesn't
exist in the vacuum you guys are
fortunate enough to have your own you
know building here on campus but that's
not the norm in most places you know
you're stuck usually with somebody else
you know we can say that analytic
philosophy historically and probably
even in the present gets along better
with
the sciences and continental philosophy
with the humanities do you say that's
that's a fair assessment
in quite a few places where where the
philosophy department is analytic much
of the continental philosophy will
actually get done in the human the other
humanities departments like the english
department history department poli sci
um you know
now um
[Music]
what about uh social sciences
i brought that up a little bit earlier
psychology anthropology
economics
do they
fall out on one side or the other neatly
like that
it really depends on where you are
doesn't it and what which one you're
looking at anthropology
it depends on you know how you're doing
it
some of the major contributors are
continental philosophers they're part of
the canon
levee strauss
so it's it's a little bit harder to to
characterize it but perhaps there's some
merit to that what about characteristic
methods this is probably getting us
closer to the heart of the the
difference
so these include basic attitudes towards
arguments and texts
maybe that is closer to the heart of the
difference between continental and
analytic philosophy
it would reflect how philosophy gets
done not only in its its publications
but also how it gets done in the
classroom in formation which is i think
perhaps even more important than
publication you know who
how do you show people
what philosophizing or doing philosophy
looks like
you know philosophy isn't something i
think where you can have a
easy book for how to do it that leads
you through 10 easy steps
just do these right it's something that
it's a skill that we we get or a set of
skills that we get
introduced
as something like apprentices
and work our way towards something like
mastery but i'm not quite sure you know
if we can specify what that is
here we can talk about distinctive
movements or schools though arising in
continental and analytic philosophy this
is an important
distinction let's say we take
continental philosophy because that
one's a lot easier to focus on is there
a continental approach
is there is there one basic
approach that undergirds
let's not even say all just
most
continental philosophy
let's say we don't even worry about like
how it's done today
just it's key figures
i see some shaking heads why not
can't we say well they love texts
they they believe in you know
doing critical reading of texts
well not all of them do i mean
some certainly do
you don't recognize the text after hegel
has digested it i can tell you that
because it is it is really interesting
works like the phenomenology
uh he doesn't even name who he's talking
about
you'd have to figure out the illusions
yourself and in his lectures
um some of his his
some of what goes into hagel's middle
comes out looking very different than
the people he names so you know the
stoic says hegel finishes with them
don't look at that much like stoicism um
well heidegger certainly love texts
he talks an awful lot about that and
people who are
interested in hiding or do what about
houston was supposed to roll into
reading texts
postero would begin each day
by doing these
extraordinarily detailed and from my
perspective they'll probably get in
trouble with a few people saying this
incredibly boring
analysis the phenomenological
descriptions
uh that exist in the hospital archive
and if you want to be a hysterical
scholar you go over there you learn to
read a shorthand and then you study some
of these that nobody else has read
before and you write a little monograph
on it and um
that's very different than than say you
know heideggerian
hermeneutics of texts i don't think
there is a
one single approach that you can point
to there's a lot of different some
movements within within continental
philosophy what about analytic
philosophy then is there something
that we can say
today
maybe in the past we could
but is there something today that we can
say constitutes the analytic approach
you guys are analytic philosophers or
analytic philosophers in training
you know what would you say
i i would say no but i'm in a less
qualified position to say anything about
that
what you have here on the handout is a
good place to start yet on the analytics
side
provides analysis of concepts arguments
intuitions uses of language
i feel like i can understand what that
is but when i look on the continental
side it says provides descriptions of
experience
textual analysis critique or liberation
and i i one when i on the analytics side
i i recognize that as philosophical um
methods yeah but on the continental side
it looks you know we were talking about
textual
analysis yeah that strikes me as
something
either narrowly conceptualized or
something you would do
studying literature
or more broadly it's something that any
academic would do yeah
well not any academic because you know
you're not going to find that many um
people in the natural sciences doing
that but but yeah in general you're
right yeah what i mean is there's a
broad and a narrow way of
thinking of textual analysis i think i
analyze texts when i read them yeah
but i don't know that i practice got no
philosophy well it's interesting too
because the
different groups within
continental philosophy don't mean the
same things by by analyzing texts like a
marxist is looking for certain things
um somebody who's who's working
within a broadly you know psychoanalytic
tradition is looking for other things
some of them didn't analyze text at all
they just wrote their own stuff
i guess what i wanted to ask you is
actually
from my perspective i think i would like
to admit my perspective
bias in some ways
but it strikes me that the methods of
analytic philosophy as
simplified here has a unity and
coherence to it
but i don't understand the
if there is a method of continental
flushing i don't think there is i think
there's methods methods yeah yeah and i
don't i'm not even sure that there is
today a method for analytic philosophy
this is
you know this isn't simplification yeah
yeah yeah because um
you know you look at the history of you
read the analytic text the core cortex
for their history
and often they don't have that much in
common with each other
as far as the method goes
we can say that they are broadly
engaging in some kind of attempt to
provide arguments
you know be clear about things
but that's about as far as we get i
think and you know it it's it's really
interesting to me moving in the kinds of
circles that i do
that when
when i um
when i talk with my analytic friends and
colleagues
in one area
what i
find about what they're doing or
interested in doesn't carry forth into
another area that's why some people talk
about this being a post-analytic period
where the
um you know even the vocabulary although
the same term will be used um
like externalism and internalism means
something very different in one one area
like philosophy of action
as it does in
another
area and so from my perspective
historically it ends up looking a lot
like um
uh
some of the things we used to say about
scholasticism
where you know
concentration on
working with with uh
terms that have been essentially their
neologism coined in order to carry out
work and they don't always like
translate from one
side to the other so i think that
analytic philosophy is in a different
condition than it was
um you know like back when i was in my
philosophical formation
and i don't know i have no idea where
it's going to go
myself because i
you know i'm not
i'm not really qualified to say that but
but it does seem like it's harder and
harder to find a
substantive
common core to an analytic method or an
analytic approach
you know these generalities like being
clear
um
what does it mean to be clear you know
you might say there's a if we want to be
kind of joking there's a bit of
obscurity about that
there's also um
i brought up the aims of philosophy
itself um
and maybe maybe that's a way to
differentiate between them i'm not
really sure if it works well some of
these are like what we're talking about
you know clarity and presentation uh
mainly through focus on the structure of
arguments um that's that's something the
analytics seem to be particularly good
at
adequately setting up good authors
position and contributions before
engaging in critique and suggesting
further lines to explore
some continental philosophers are very
good at that um some of them are very
very bad at that
um
then there's sort of grander scale
things you know and and i i think that
these tend to be more associated with
continental philosophy like you know
overcoming western metaphysics
uh is a big project
um
which by the way i don't think anybody
really knows what that that means at
this point it's meant so many different
things
but um
that's very clearly something different
than what
many analytic philosophers would
want to talk about
um but you know we can talk about things
that pop up in analytic philosophy there
is a lot of in analytic philosophy of
religion there's a lot of work done by
theistic philosophers that's essentially
what we used to call apologetics
aimed at demonstrating the rationality
of religious faith or doctrines
not so much that incontinental these
days
in part because continental philosophy
isn't all european philosophy it's just
sort of a some sector of it
but you see that it can be quite
difficult to characterize these but
let's let's try a little bit more with
the analytic philosophy
so maybe
we put aside the you know location stuff
um
maybe looking at its its history might
prove useful
um
what's sort of the the
the doctrine about where did analytic
philosophy come from
why did it emerge as a movement
my understanding is that it started with
frank and russell creating basically
predicate logic
yeah now notice that by
talking about it that way you focused
already on two of the key
thinkers in it and a very important
movement within it
um
russell wasn't just motivated to
do logic
he said frank was i think
you know and he had some interesting
motives
for what he was doing as it turned out
later on
um
why did russell get into it
he didn't love logic just for its own
sake
it was a reaction against something
does anybody know what they were
reacting against
no
british idealism yeah now what is it
what does that mean that was a you know
it means i'm good at reading oh
then i put that on there i forgot okay
so these were yellows these are these
are people you know
we kind of forget how how uh
you know hegel and continental
philosophy is a total aside hagel and
continental philosophy
is primarily coming from engagement with
his phenomenology of spirit and
primarily with one sub-section of it
called the master slave
uh dialectic and some some thinkers like
slavo giac actually read the whole text
most read just just a portion of it
and in the 19th century that book wasn't
really read much people weren't that
interested in that they were much more
interested in his logic and his you know
system capital s which was supposed to
take in everything
and so there were these british
idealists who were doing similar
projects
they're very interesting people to read
some of them had some interesting
insights but they would talk in pretty
murky terms you know the absolute winds
up being everywhere
um russell understandably you know
wanted to know what are they actually
talking about uh thought a lot of what
they were saying was kind of kind of
vacuous
and so the ideal behind you know
focusing on logic is we can rebuild
things from the ground up and that's
what you call the logistics project as
russell and and whitehead originally
conceived of it that's a very important
you know beginning point in analytic
philosophy
um
the early event can shine kind of fits
into that in a weird eccentric way he's
sort of like a comet coming in and you
know just going you know on his on his
own orbit um
there were
advances in mathematics and logic and
understanding of language that were
underway great promise
involved in that um and
you know another thing to understand
historically is the importance of other
philosophical movements
in the background it's not as if they
totally rejected all you know previous
philosophy
um the the positivist movement itself is
going to show up again in logical
positivism which didn't you know there's
a reason why why it's positivism
the 19th century saw some pretty
important thinkers in that respect
analytic ethics uh think about g more
who is he primarily concerned in dealing
with the utilitarians that that whole
thing provides a background
um and then you know
in some ways
analytic philosophy saw itself early on
as a continuance of the empiricist
project
um
so you know there's
references uh not a lot of you know
direct references but you know thinking
out things in terms of
mill and hume
um
an emphasis on on
what can actually be empirically
attested or verified as we see in the
verificationist attempt
and all that
and it you know it continues its
development throughout the 20th century
within a tradition it's very interesting
work done
um and there's a whole bunch of other
you might say spin off
projects or ways of doing things think
about how different if you've read
russell's you know philosophy of logical
atomism
and then you compare that to
wittgenstein's philosophical
investigations they really are quite
different stuff or you compare either of
those to somebody like like ryle writing
later on
you know doing doing uh
you know continuing this analysis
focusing on ordinary language really
quite you know
distinct movements developing and it
continues up so by the time that i'm in
graduate school
um you know the the
the whole discussion about possible
worlds had become
part of the parlance and it was
something that we were getting
introduced to very very interesting
stuff as well
now um
analytic philosophy effectively becomes
dominant in in the anglosphere and in
scandinavia
and
you know how does it how does it
identify itself is it is it by reference
to this canon how many of
you would say
and i don't feel i'm not trying to put
anybody on the spot so just think about
this how many of you would say that you
really engage the canon the of you know
classic analytic philosophical texts on
a continuing basis that you see that is
important
do you see it as important
or is it something that can be
successfully left behind like you know
rickenstein's old metaphor of the ladder
that you pull up you know which he got i
think out of
uh if i remember right
some mystic text to the christian
tradition
now why wouldn't a canon be important
it's more focused on natural sciences
natural logic and
disease
oh yeah well i i don't there's nobody in
the
classic literatures you know sort of
like quoting him chapter and verse and
saying here's how we do
humans well humans okay
exactly that you um
yeah um
although you know they they really did
if you look back on that literature they
did raise some really central
issues and suggest some some
trajectories
um
some of which they later on rejected aj
here by the way is a great person for
you know you look at what he said in his
later years about uh his earlier work he
said almost all of it was wrong you know
but it was it was great that he he did
it
do they need do you need reference
points or maybe maybe uh that's no
longer important yeah i was um
you know the names attached to the ideas
seem less important to me um you mean
like the movements or no no the the
specific authors okay
i mean like knowing uh that is an
article i'm reading came from russell
might be useful for getting to
understand exactly what he's talking
about because russell has a specific way
of talking yeah
more importantly are the central themes
and um the time period the conversation
going on in philosophy at the time
so the yeah the canon is important in so
far as it's useful to learn about what
is happening in philosophy right now
what was happening previously what ideas
emerged but
the ideas are more important to me than
the actual text yeah or the claims you
might say yeah the claims the arguments
the concepts yeah i
i think that makes sense
um
and we might be at a point too where
enough like some literatures have grown
up
uh
by the way too this is one of the things
i'll talk about towards the end we're in
a different situation as well as far as
time where it's not really possible to
master some sort of you know
comprehensive canon of contemporary
analytic philosophical so much stuff out
there any more than you could with with
continental but i'll talk about why that
matters in a bit
um
you know what do you guys make of of
sort of you might say that the
uh
i'm not sure how to describe it but
there are many people working within
analytic philosophy who are coming in
from other substantive
philosophical traditions like analytic
thomas the people who you know are
coming out of stump's
school
who take you know they're doing
something taking thomas aquinas and
sometimes some others and trying to
put it into an analytics thing
robert brandon's trying to do that with
hagel
i'm not sure how how successfully
because i haven't really read his stuff
there's analytic marxists out there who
who there's a big going project for a
while they want to take marx who's
pretty
obscure in points and and take his his
arguments and put them into an analytic
framework it would seem that there then
there must be something pretty
definitive about the analytic
framework in order to do that it's a
formula that you're learning and then
you can take the formula and apply it to
other places you said
i'm
i don't know i i i don't i get the
impression of logic you can learn how to
do logic and then you take it and you
use it yeah find out who the person was
that
taught you
but analytic philosophy is much more
than just the application of logic
um
you know there is like
the sort of having to parse out what
what arguments are i'm sure you can put
arguments into a logical form that used
to be very popular by the way when i was
in formation the analytics would spend a
lot of time putting things into a formal
logic notation and then translating them
back again and saying okay this is what
we did and we'd be like well why didn't
why did you do that you know um i think
nowadays it's it's it is still done
i'm going on very limited experience
because i don't read as much athletic
philosophy
especially contemporary stuff as i'd
like like to but
um i get the idea that there's much more
just let's try to make things clearer
and present them in a way that
then we can see whether they stand up or
not
not just
putting them into a logical form i can
say this as somebody who studied st
thomas myself i don't i don't really
find what the analytic tom thomas do to
be very rooted in thomas after a while
it looks
much more like doing analytic philosophy
that with a little bit of thomas thrown
in than you know doing anything
substantively to mystic but um i'm sure
they they see it very different
there's one other thing too i'd like to
say about analytic philosophy
is we're trying to sort of work that out
there are some analytics philosophers
who are excellent historians of
philosophy who have made some major
contributions
vlastos gregory vlastos and plato
scholarship
prime example
some of the people who i i read and i do
a lot of work on ansel have done some
really interesting
work as well
um
so
yeah
that's probably enough at this point
about analytic because
you know it's sort of like a preaching
to the the choir here um what about
continental philosophy
um i don't think there is any such thing
as continental philosophy in a strict
sense
myself
um
because there isn't one single coherent
perspective to it and i will admit too
there is what we could call a
continental stick or
a repertoire
if you go in some continental circles or
read certain journals
um
it's not just confined to students but
often found among some professors where
they just you know use some jargon
invoke some key doctrines
it used to be very popular when i was a
graduate student that we had to
deconstruct everything
now it's much more in terms of rhizome
and if you ask people what does that
mean they'll tell you about grass and
you know roots but there isn't there
isn't a lot there are some people who do
it really well
those people are pretty rare there's a
lot more people just talking uh about
this sort of stuff than
than doing something i would say that's
very rigorous
historically i would say the existence
of what we call continental philosophy
is
the product of history
prior to analytic philosophy attaining
dominance in britain and america there
used to be a lot of interaction and
influence between french and german and
english-speaking philosophical
circles and you can see this reflected
you know just
look at you know correspondence between
people like james and bergson
for an example
then
there was also a stronger focus on
figures in the history of philosophy so
that allowed kind of a shared
you know
formation you could say or a shared set
of reference points but the rise of
analytic philosophy in in britain and
the united states there was much less of
that there was a tendency to set aside
non-analytic philosophers as sort of
unimportant as merely historical
uh as not really philosophy but
something masquerading as philosophy
ryle was a great example of making those
sort of claims as he did as he engaged
in an attempt to try to have a dialogue
with with continental philosophers
the newer continental thought made its
way into the american academic scene
in significant part through
two main sources one was catholic
schools because there'd been a
long-standing connection and they they
went some of them have gone analytic
many of them went analytic fairly late
uh and then also sort of radical schools
like the new school in in
new york right
um
and um
eventually like in 1962 you see the
society for phenomenological
and existential philosophy being created
as sort of a counterweight to the apa
which was felt to be
so analytic and so hostile to
continental philosophy that they wanted
to have their own space
i'm not sure that that was really the
case
you know looking back at it historically
there was there were still panels on
on
people in the continental tradition at
the apa
and i'm not sure that that's really the
the case quite so much today but they
there was you know for a while kind of
this this rivalry
and um there ends up being sort of this
this goes to like why it would be you
know more oriented with literature and
with
other you know humanities fields or
studies fields right
there there's a lot of interconnections
and overlaps with other
movements
like marxism feminism africana
philosophy
you know and
there's a lot of tie-ins with with other
um
fields as well
so what ends up developing is a kind of
sense of opposition
of being an alternative be a philosophy
being in a crisis and the analytics are
not you know doing a good job with
philosophy they're actually like maybe
doing anti-philosophy this is the kind
of stuff people talked about quite a bit
when i was in graduate school
and
the idea was that by doing continental
philosophy you were doing something that
was
restoring philosophy to what it was
supposed to be continental philosophy
as
as we understand it here is really i
would say more of an
anglo-american thing
than what actually happens in europe
it's a pretty selective
cross-section of european philosophy
leaving out a lot of contemporary people
who aren't you know
fitting into that vein historically
leaving out a lot of people
as well
um
and
even with that even with confining it
like that i still don't think there's an
internal coherence to it i think it's
more something defined by by opposition
to analytic philosophy because we can
say that there are
uh a lot of different um
approaches within continental philosophy
so
you know it used to be that we would
talk in terms of the three h's of
phenomenology would those be
through three h guys
cyril heidegger
yeah very good and now if you if you
actually read
them
you find out that they mean very
different things by phenomenology even
even heidegger and his role there's a
huge difference between them
um and in their approach
[Music]
another way that we would talk about it
sometimes is the hermeneutics of
suspicion paul recur came up with this
this great phrase and he said that you
know continental philosophy uh you know
he has a
attitude of suspicion of de-masking
you know pulling back the
veil from things and so he talked about
marx doing so with economic life freud
doing so with desire and sexuality
nietzsche doing so with power
and and
all sorts of other things another way
you might think about it is
i don't know if you've any of you have
ever seen richard kearney's
um
pretty decent continental philosophy
reader
have any of you ever seen that in a
bookstore
it's kind of a standard text for
for continental philosophy classes and
it covers the 20th century
so he divides it into three main groups
from any he has from phenomenology to
hermeneutics
there is historically a continuity there
starting out with his role going to the
core
um
that there's some some continuity
although he leaves out
quite a few of the people who would fit
in there marxism the critical theory
okay that makes sense too if you know
what you know what those are teaching
and then from structuralism to
deconstruction that's the kitchen sink
or the the junk drawer rather you know
you know the junk drawer any of you had
that it's a miscellaneous drawer you
always anytime you have a classification
or those of you who do budgets i don't
have to tell any of you who actually do
budgets
always have a miscellaneous expenses
category
because everything that you can't fit
into the other ones that goes in there
right
that's that that category structuralism
to deconstruction that's everybody
from dissociate to derrida and a whole
bunch of other people in between who
don't really have much in common with
each other methodologically
and a lot ends up being left out in any
attempt to corral in figures that we
take to be continental philosophy
um
and it's it's it's also important to
point out that there while there are
some philosophers
who um
place themselves in you know they
self-identify as continental
philosophers
and they can say very well informed
things about and applying the key ideas
and approaches of many of the canonical
thinkers
that's a tough task
it's very difficult to
survey the field of even official we
might call it official continental
philosophy
and to be proficient in all those
thinkers
so it's more the exception than the rule
there tends to be a lot of
specialization
in among continental philosophers
and it's similar in analytic philosophy
right people specialize in this area
rather than that area in this in this
case it's more often in terms of texts
and thinkers
so somebody might for example say that
they're a phenomenologist and they focus
on edmund husterel
and maurice marileponte
and they'll know some basic ideas of
heidegger and jean-paul sark and lebanos
and mario because those are people that
you're probably going to have to teach
and and people still talk about
but they will
never have read more than snippets of
other major phenomenologists
who are there's you know quite a big
literature on like like uh mark schaeler
or uh edith stein or gabriel marcel or
dietrich von hildenbrand
um just to name a few now that's just in
phenomenology
that's not even talking about say
hermeneutics
or psychoanalytic theory or you know we
can add more and more and more
there's a lot of this this
specialization
some people even just specialize in one
text of a major thinker you know i only
work on on you know this later work of
heidegger don't ask me about being in
time
um so i'd like to point out that within
this wide spectrum that we're defining
as continental philosophy there's some
really varied attitudes towards
philosophy's history
some of these thinkers just seem to kind
of mine the past thinkers and texts for
ideas they strip them out of their
context they're only interested in them
insofar as they're part of some
uh you might say
liberatory agenda
shield to lose is a great example of
somebody like that i would say
some situate their own work through some
really serious and thoughtful engagement
to their continuity with past thinkers
um somebody who's a contemporary example
of that i would say would be giorgio
agamben if you've ever read his stuff
when he teaches classes
he's he's teaching um you know aristotle
and augustine and he's placing his
thought hobbs a lot he places his
thought in continuity with the past
um some see the past thought as
something to overcome
um heidegger you could say saw things
that way
um
we should also point out too that
there's a lot of crosstalk and critique
among continental thinkers
you know they can often be tougher on
each other than they are towards any
analytic
because it's sort of like a family
battle
um
so is there any sort of essence that we
can point to is continental philosophy i
don't think so
i mean do you didn't you after
all those sort of
talking points see anything in there
that we could find an essence or
a characterization maybe even
we everyone knows about wittgenstein and
family resemblance right
games there's lots of different kinds of
games that's the closest we're going to
come to for what continental philosophy
counts as so i don't know that this
chart is actually that useful
in some respects
now
what about the divide then
what what happens to it
clearly there is some difference between
analytic and continental philosophy
so
what are the differences well there's a
difference in who is considered worth
reading and thinking about and how and
what to read and think about them you
know what what one motive is for for
reading them right that's that's part of
it
there's clearly stylistic differences
do there's an analytic there's a
philosophy this is a a uh sorry an
article in a primarily analytic journal
read like something that you'd find in a
primarily continental journal
not usually
maybe they sneak something in every once
in a while i don't know i would have to
do a survey
um so there are stylistic differences we
can talk about different dialects or
idioms perhaps in philosophical
discourse and there's geomet
geographical and departmental
differences
um some places you know it's it's
primarily analytics some places
primarily continental you always have to
ask with continental what kind of
continental because they don't always
get along and agree with each other
but one thing i'd like to point out and
stress again there's gaps and divides
within analytic and continental
philosophy themselves
so
there's a gap between the present and
the past
i think that if you were to ask
you know 40 years ago
about a canon of analytic philosophy or
i even even when i was in graduate
school if you were an analytic if you
were a student studying analytic
philosophy you actually read the canon
of analytic philosophy
you may afterwards say i'm not going to
bother with these guys because i'm just
doing you know
possible world stuff
but
you would you would read it and maybe
have to respond to it i don't think
that's necessarily the case these days
is it
um what about continental philosophy
there's a huge gap between the presence
of continental philosophy and its past i
think in some ways and again
probably going to provoke some
reaction from viewers with this i think
it was done in more serious ways in the
past
by some of the thinkers that it's being
done
by some of them today
um
there's also gaps in the in the present
and and we already talked about that
with with continental philosophy you
know marxists and
psychoanalysts don't always get along
just to pick a few things about marxists
and phenomenologists usually that's a
that's a great one phenomenologist
anybody often times
um what about an analytic philosophy
and i don't mean things like you know
having schools you know
facing off against each other
let me ask you this
does somebody who is working
in
ethics broadly construed in the analytic
tradition
um do they share the same or even a
overlapping reading list
with somebody doing
epistemology
or metaphysics
yeah absolutely do you think so
yeah you think they all read the same
articles no no no no but there's a
significant overlap okay you know if
you're thinking venn diagrams of course
there's lots of stuff
different but there's a core that they
are all going to read okay absolutely i
don't find that to be the case
among a lot of my my younger analytic
peers
but
i probably know much less about that
my sample size is smaller
you know
i mean it looks to me as if there's
there's
growing divergences between
different discourses with an analytic
lawsuit they're not actually reading
each other
and sometimes the language
the same terminology doesn't mean the
same thing going from discourse to
discourse so it always has to be defined
um
i just asked the question about it
absolutely that's absolutely right you
know that the word externalism gets used
different ways
to suppose uh you know libertarianism
means well we're talking about free will
and something else when you're talking
about political philosophy yeah um
but why isn't that just a simple case of
ambiguity i mean it's not i mean you
know we can do this all the time right
and uh you know anybody who works on
free will and political philosophy just
that's okay when i'm doing
philosophy i mean one thing by
libertarianism when you're doing pretty
well i mean something else
yeah and generally they have to specify
that uh at the beginning when they use
the term right
i don't see that as
just by itself being
you know how how these different fields
are different i think it's just a sign
of how divergent they end up becoming
right but it's not impediment to
communication being skills right in
theory you're right yeah
i think that there's a lot of um
what's happening over here
ends up just going its own way
and what's happening over here
has ends up having very little
connection with it other than they're
doing they're using some sort of
broadly analytic approach to it you know
um
you kind of ask a different question
yeah i probably should have asked an
hour ago
so it's always seemed to me that uh that
the term analytic
as achievement philosophy is ambiguous
in a way that's very analogous to the
way the word classical is used in music
right so sometimes if you're talking to
serious musicians you know they'll
they'll say well what i mean by
classical music is a very distinctive
style you know typified by mozart that
was prevalent in the late 18th century
and very early 19th century in vienna
and that's classical music right okay
and mussorgsky is not a classical
musician right and neither is mark and
so yeah but there's this other much
broader use where we what most of us
mean by classical music is just sort of
high brow music yeah
it includes everything from morocco
to contemporary stuff and i think so
long as there's like violins yeah
there's some stuff like that
the composer has a russian or german
name
well not necessarily okay so so so in
philosophy you know there is
there is this uh
very somewhat narrowly construed notion
of
which is the analysis of concepts and
languages you know we associate with
ryle and austin and people like that
yeah and that's a pretty well defined
thing but
reasonably i mean i'm not saying we can
give necessary special conditions but i
mean we can all identify what counts as
that yeah but there's this much broader
sense i mean very you know you said this
is an analytic department and i think
that's a fair characterization but not
in that narrow sense right yeah right
we're analytic in the way that you know
rachmaninoff is classical uh
yeah
i mean that that style
let's call it analytic one yeah it's
just not a going it hasn't been blowing
concern for a long time yeah so what is
this broader thing well look as with
classical music in the broad sense you
can't give you know precise identity
conditions for it but you can recognize
it pretty well and as you said it has a
lot to do with you know
giving arguments yeah striving often
failing but striving for clarity and
precoc
you know does continental philosophy
what how does kind of plastic fit into
that well i don't know i mean some of it
probably is that condition
oh yeah that's a very good point i mean
that's one of the things that people
have been writing on this
point out you know like in in terms of
like uh
for example you want some very
detailed analyses
of um not so much language they did do
some some stuff with language uh he does
he does that um
there there are some continental
philosophers who've made i was going to
talk about this a bit later made a great
effort to try to reach across
the the
gap or the divide and frame things in
ways that would be that would aim for
clarity not always achieving it i mean
habermas is a great example i don't
think habermas is
extraordinarily clear
uh but i think he's striving for that i
agree yeah about striding or about him
but how about striving yeah yeah yeah i
think however much
is uh
is we're greeting right yeah
i mean what my my thought about harper
months is that insofar as i have been
able to make sense of what he said i
think yeah it makes perfect sense and
it's not all that interesting
you know i mean
once you pair it down and get how the
body's really saying it turns out to be
fairly trivial yeah well
we could come up with
many examples of that
so
let's go back to this issue of the
divide and how it fits in so let's and
let's say that there is some
common core approach to the analytic
philosophy um i think that you know at
this point the divide has become
more so as they say sociological
than
rooted in some sort of you know
essential difference
but that doesn't mean that it doesn't
exist or that it's going to go away i
think the biggest factors i'm going to
talk about a bit later is actually is
actually time
and the requirements that time would
impose on this
the history of the divide you do have to
admit has involved a lot of unnecessary
bashing
misrepresentations even attempts to push
out the other side from institutional
spaces one of the graduate schools that
i applied to when i was applying for
graduate school back in 94
actually sent me a letter back saying
we're no longer for the time being we
don't have a graduate program and as it
turned out they had a big fight the way
it sometimes happens and the analytics
were forced out by the continentals
and they lost so many faculty that for
the time being they had to curtail
accepting any new graduate students
that sort of thing has been the case in
the past i think
and i don't know you know whether this
is really the case but i think that it's
it's
much less common now you know that there
is some some recognition of pluralism
um i think that from a historical
perspective
if we look at it as a
genuine rivalry it doesn't seem to be
anything necessary to
philosophy itself it's not necessary for
the present time
but there are some historically created
gaps of understanding between analytic
and continental formed philosophers
but the other thing i'd like to say too
is the notion of them sort of carving up
the available space that gets put out
there and you know in
charts like like this
i think is very parochial
it ignores all the other stuff that that
there is to do in philosophy and that is
getting done
um now granted
i would say american philosophy
departments are for the most part either
analytic or continentally oriented
although there are some ones that
really do focus on
classical american philosophy or doing
history of philosophy extraordinarily
well
um
so how might we view this divide then i
i would say we should understand it as
an important feature
of the contemporary and likely future
philosophical scene
but we want to broaden our horizons
beyond it
and we should look for models provided
by thinkers like habermas for example
who try to
make genuine efforts to to bridge this
divide
somebody who i would point to in the
history of analytic philosophy who did
that and i think did that quite well but
not in a systematic way it was john
wisdom
who is kind of a minor figure but very
very interesting to read he thought that
he would you know take a look at what
sark was writing and see if there was
anything to it
he was interested in psychoanalysis
um so you know you see somebody actually
trying to do that paul recur great
example if you ever read the rule of
metaphor he's explicitly engaging
contemporary um
analytic philosophy of language and then
i'd say there's some interesting
defectors as well that are worth taking
a look at one of these is richard rorty
who starts out in analytic philosophy
and then eventually um
you know does his own thing i don't you
know they want to say that he's like you
know in the american pragmatist
tradition but i don't really know about
that i think he's more doing his own
thing informed by some things from
analytic philosophy some things from
american pragmatism and informed by some
things from continental philosophy
another one aleister mcintyre
aleister mcintyre gets a start in
analytic philosophy he's clearly not an
analytic philosopher
but he's clearly not a continental
philosopher either he's doing something
that he calls tradition constituted
rationality that you know
whether he gets his history of
philosophy right or not he's been
criticized by you know the kierkegaard
scholars about his caregiver he's been
criticized by the stoic scholars about
his views on stoicism so there are some
you know
he is at least trying to think in a
historical perspective
so let's talk then about you know what i
was supposed to talk about what can
analytic and continental philosophers
learn from each other
and there's there's a number of ways we
can answer this
for present-day philosophers we can say
what can analytic philosophers learn
from reading philosophers within the
continental canon and vice versa
what can analytic philosophers learn
from reading contemporary continental
philosophers including secondary
literature or adaptations and vice versa
what can analytic philosophers learn by
engaging in dialogue and discussion with
continental philosophers and what can
continental philosophers learn by that
and then what more general features
characteristic of both could be learned
and if you ask these questions and you
really try to answer them there's a
presumption
that something non-trivial is there to
be learned from each other
that
no one approach totally monopolizes
what what what counts as philosophy so
maybe you find something that
supplements your way of engaging in
philosophy now it should be unsurprising
at this point that my answers are going
to suggest that some of the things that
can be learned are not exclusive to
analytic or continental philosophies but
to other approaches as well
so general features when i thought about
this you know the approach in the style
of analytics so analytic philosophy does
in general get done with this guiding
ideal of clear well-organized prose
not just arguments but clear
well-organized prose which i think is
important
providing explicitly worked out
arguments identifying what might be
questionable assumptions or intuitions
could continental philosophers benefit
by
trying to adopt that idiom i think they
probably could many of them i think some
of them in doing so would discover that
their research project turned out to be
a failure
and so you know there's a lot of
engaging in obscurity
uh
you know because it prevents one from
having to say there's really not much
here
but it would be good as well
for seeing what what really is there
at the very least it's a useful exercise
to try to translate what one wants to
say into a different style or idiom i
think
analytic philosophers when they're doing
their work well are quite selective in
engagement with literature on their
topic
here's one of what i consider a strength
of analytic philosophy when they make
references to literature like say
footnoting
it's usually relevant
and and you know
centrally relevant not just tangentially
relevant
that would also be useful for some
continental philosophers to consider as
a you know
writing tip right
now
going the other way some continental
philosophers have a really robust
engagement with thinkers and texts and
they aim at systematically understanding
a philosophical perspective as they
engage with it not only in its own terms
but also in terms of its context and
structure and relevance and i think that
can be useful for analytic philosophers
to acquire as a skill learning how to
read text
not just in terms of dissociated claims
and arguments i'm not saying there's
anything wrong with that but you lose a
lot by doing that
and
continental philosophers are also
you might say more let's just call it
adventurous in their their choice of
subject matter what they're willing to
to draw upon although i think you know
if you look at content more more recent
analytic philosophy
it's harder to say that you know there's
there's huge areas of human experience
that are being left out there's so much
work being done
um but i think that you know looking at
some of the examples could be could be
useful for them um i think both sides
genuinely engaging each other helps to
overcome a kind of
you know
not not closed mindedness but you know
having blinders on only seeing a very
small portion
of philosophy an assumption that only
one mode is is legitimate
um
and i actually would like to use a just
you know sort of an analogy to what
descartes says in his discourse on
method
he uh suggests that travel is a really
great idea he had been a fan of the gap
year right
the term that people use these days for
the year that you're not in school
and the reason he was a he was really a
fan of that
other than the fact that he had enough
money to travel i think is that
he said that by by watching people
you get to see
how they engage in
you know reasoning about their world
you get to see a whole bunch of other
perspectives in action and he thought
that was a good thing he thought you
couldn't do that so much from books
i think he's probably wrong about that i
think looking at how other people do
philosophy could could be quite quite
useful
um
and it breaks us free from a kind of uh
you know you might say
conformity that that can be
restricted at times so that could be a
value that's centrally involved in
philosophy i know it has been in the
past
you know talk as if you know when we're
introducing it to
undergraduates as if that's what
philosophy does so that could be good
what about reading each other's
canonical figures um
now
what it recognizes classic texts and
important thinkers
are usually worth reading at least in my
experience
for both the continental figures
and analytic figures but then again i
really enjoy reading philosophical texts
what can you do through that you can get
introduced to alternative philosophical
perspectives and themes
uh ideas that some really intelligent
people
took seriously and found worth worth
thinking through
it also saves a bit of time from
reinventing wheels um
this is this is one of my complaints
as i engage sometimes with
colleagues doing things like virtue
epistemology
which is primarily an analytic concern
um
you know
they can they'll do a lot of work and
then you'll say yeah aristotle already
did that
um now there's there's you know now
we're not talking about aerosol but
continental philosophy there's some
things i think where it could be good to
get ideas from continental thinkers and
i think there's uh this is what recorder
recognized the rule of metaphor
sometimes the analytics are way ahead of
the continentals on some important
things like how to understand metaphor
you can also
understand or ascertain limitations or
or failures in those texts for yourself
rather than relying on secondary losses
if you want to know whether hegel is
indecipherable read hagel
and then you know it won't take long
before
you're getting that impression i'm
saying this is somebody who likes hate
um
if you want to see whether
um heineger is really on to something or
not you probably got to read some hiding
and actually read it not just sort of
you know skim through it but but see
what's what's there
um
you can see where the the problem of
time is starting to raise its head
though right
what about contemporary literature i
think you can say a lot of the same
things about contemporary literature the
problem is
there's too much of it
there's there's waste
being churned out
and it's tougher to see what it what in
it is classic because every book jacket
says that this is the best text ever
that that came out
um
so it's hard to say exactly where you
would go for for guidance on that
and we do have to admit philosophy can
be a little bit fat or fashion driven at
times
so
that can be an issue and what about
dialogue or collaboration
i think it's useful to learn who matters
to one's interlocutors and why what
value they have what do they see in them
and then learning how to speak it's sort
of like learning how to speak a
different dialect
or perhaps even a different language in
in our discipline
um
now i i think and here's where i'm going
to put in my own two cents
much of what's particularly valuable
that either side can learn from each
other is something they can learn from
other main ways of doing philosophy as
well
if you want clear exposition focused on
setting out critically analyzing
arguments analytic philosophy doesn't
have a lock on that
all you got to do is read thomists
some of them
were real experts in that some of them
not so much
you can also find this in a lot of
historically focused work if you want to
see a focus on broader historical or
social you know contexts
you might get that better from
historical approaches than from
contemporary continental philosophy and
there is a lot there are a lot of people
out there who do work you know
in historical uh figures
um who are taking them very seriously
people who are aristotle scholars are
writing on aristotle because they think
there's something really there
and they read the whole corpus not just
you know portions of it you're not going
to find a lot of well you you will find
one uh person i can think of hagen
bender takes aristotle seriously but not
too many others
among continental thinkers
learning how to read classic works of
authors not only pre 19th or 20th
century but
even those authors who are considered to
be analytic or continental thinkers
that's something else that you know
i think historians of philosophy are are
good at
now what is the biggest obstacle i
mentioned time
when you're studying in a
in a particular
place you know
you have to look to
the people that you're studying with
if you want to broaden your horizons
about that
how do you know who to go to
you know
any choice you're going to make is going
to be something arbitrary and every bit
of research that you do
requires that you pay out some time
and
your time is limited
i know i was talking about this with
with joseph for younger people
and if i was saying this to my younger
self it feels like you have a lot of
time and actually the students who do
have in general more time than
professors do because you don't know how
much you know
nonsense professors have to put up with
quite frankly
um and then you know once you start
having you know families and things like
that that takes more time but there's
sort of like a
uh you might say
a horizon that kind of shifts around
we're not going to live forever
so when you're deciding who you're going
to read
i know i think about it this way if
somebody proposes i should read some new
text i think
well i could read this or i could
re-read some counts or i could re-read
some aristotle or i could actually get
to the hegel stuff that i'm
supposed to do or i can read some and
keep going on and on and on
you can't you can't do it all
so
you know in terms of overcoming this
this divide in theory we could
you know if we had infinite time we
could all be on both sides of the divide
and doing all kinds of philosophy but
that's not really a practical
option for us so we have to do something
almost like triage we have to decide
what we want to put our our time into so
that's actually one reason why i came up
with this this reading list
which is i think more for the students
than
anyone else this is before if you wanted
to get a
decent not a great but decent smattering
of
fairly typical continental approaches
with some works that are seen as being
pretty important and are also short for
the most part and fairly accessible some
of them less than others you know uh
baudrillard dulu is not that super
accessible um
this might be where you would start
and i picked 20 because 20 is a
convenient number you know you can have
it cut off somewhere
but i thought these these would be
useful you notice i don't have hagels
anything in there um we do have you know
kojam's introduction to the reading of
hagel i think that is
is you know
when you read koji java you're getting
more kojev than hegel but you're at
least getting some hegel in a digestive
form
um and there's a lot of you notice also
like jacques lacan i don't recommend
anybody reads the accrete to start with
because uh he's deliberately obscure
and he said so you know he said he's
going to make people work as hard as
they could let's understand that stuff
that doesn't strike me as a virtue of
his work
seminar seven
uh like many of his seminars pretty
straightforward
there's some challenging stuff in there
but it's it's much more straightforward
than uh his his uh
deliberately
difficult parts
and so i you know
this could be what you would want to do
but now imagine to yourself let's say
you did say okay i'm going to do this
how long will this take
just to go through these 20 works
could you do it in a semester
maybe if you didn't have anything else
to do
if you're just if you're just reading
these
um
so you have to make you have to make
choices about
what you would want to draw upon and
that's going to you know when we say
what can analytic and continental
philosophers learn from each other
that's going to be somewhat limited by
this factor of time more than anything
else i think more than the existence of
a divide more than the history of you
know squabbles between people
we are in a situation
where that's the the toughest factor for
us to deal with and i think for those of
us who are older
um and you know especially those of us
who've passed the point where we say
well more than half my life is probably
done statistically
it becomes very pressing i don't know i
maybe i'm generalizing too much from my
own experience but
that's that's that's all i um
have as far as that that issue
um
if you want i can tell you a little bit
about sort of reflections on this
historical
approach or we could just do general q a
if that's more interesting
i know that we're i said i've talked for
about 90 minutes and
i've done that that's
you've been very patient
listening for 90 minutes that's a long
time
you guys have questions
do you want to post them
characteristically i want to fall into
the subgroup one of the subgroups you
mentioned and you have this emphasis on
time we can only study so much why is it
not more so in interest despite the kind
of
sexist beginnings of philosophy to study
more feminist philosophy i mean
it would be in your interest to study
how the population that you share yeah
i'm actually a fan of that i i
i do work on mary wollstonecraft
uh you know if you look at the list that
i've got here there's there's quite a
few
uh women philosophers in there
um
just more so it's like a general
question of life philosophy do you think
that the problem is because of the
beginnings and you know women were seen
as more so inferior and not the rational
sex or do you think it's just
what are you asking me in general
because what at least from what i've yes
or from this
philosophy isn't
i would i would arguably say exactly
that's two cents
yeah i'd say that's generally true yeah
at this point in time um
now you're asking why that's the case
yeah do would you say that it's a
historical implications of philosophy
that you know well women can't do
philosophy or would you say well there's
some of that that was that was certainly
an impulse for a long time and there is
still some sort of old boyism that goes
on
with that i have to say that um i myself
in the places where i've worked haven't
seen much of that which is which is kind
of nice
but i you know i'm sure that you know we
still have these these big scandals that
show up in the new york times every once
in a while
more at the you know level of
institutions
um i think that in part
one of the issues is that um
feminist theory and works by women in
doing let's say let's call it philosophy
writ large
rather than just in one particular area
have often been pushed off to other
departments
like women's studies well we don't have
to have a
you know discussion of this because they
can go take a class over there or to
english departments in particular
um
i
almost i teach wollstonecraft when i
teach intro and ethics classes sometimes
i'm probably pretty
unusual in doing that
including among my female colleagues
usually she'll get taught in a class on
feminism
or women and gender or you know whatever
it's named right
uh and then she's just you know one
example among many
um
what else
i mean you asked if it's there's some
historical
basis for it yeah i mean
you know
i mentioned that i do a lot of work on
aristotle and i teach aristotle every
time i teach an ethics class and usually
when i'm teaching it most places that
i've taught it's to a class that
includes more women than men
and so um you know
when when we get to talking about his
remarks about women which are pretty
poorly informed
and have done some great historical uh
historically have done some great
uh
damage in setting back you know equality
because of the way that he was used
i i say this i say you know if you think
about aristotle and his method in
general
what would he do if we brought him into
the classroom he'd have some real
culture shock to begin with
and then what if you pointed out to him
that we're reading this this text and
it's primarily that the female students
are actually raising their hands
outcomes
are worse in most college
settings for
for male students you know retention
rates are lower uh women tend to be
doing better
what do you make of that buddy you know
what do you think about that he i think
aristotle would probably say well i
think i need to reconsider some of my my
statements and the
premises that i was drawing them from
because clearly they're they're you know
they're not well-founded um
and so it's it's it's you know
it's probably going to take several
generations just to say defang aristotle
um
let alone others
but you know
you've got somebody receptive here to
having more women in the curriculum
um when i teach descartes i i include
the
correspondence with with elizabeth who
he treated as an equal
you know
it's interesting too because
i'm doing a
piece on woolstonecraft as a virtuous
even in the virtue ethics community she
is uh and in the history of philosophy
of moral philosophy community almost no
mention of her
you know just too bad uh
so that's that's a bit of a digression
any other
questions or did that answer yeah
especially okay yeah
do you think there's need for this kind
of builds off what you were discussing
um do you think that there's some kind
of need for
almost a uh it's a meta philosophy
um to sort of start the conversation on
what works from the different
disciplines continental even eastern
uh philosophy are worth delving into
to start building
um sort of a more
global
philosophical school
well
or do you think that we should just let
it happen more naturally and
let the the sort of bridging of the
divide happen as it
does over time i think it's good to have
efforts
that are set in place to do that and
there are some going on you know
um some of that gets done under the
rubric of comparative philosophy okay
and there are even like grant programs
like they'll you know there's money to
like take philosophers from from the
states and then bring them over to china
and have you know some interaction
um but it's a pretty small
proportion of
people that that's affected a
metaphilosophy
any metapholosis is always going to be
from somebody's perspective so it's it's
you know anytime you try to have some
overarching thing
it's something that uh
somebody's gonna run it you know
i guess i'm sort of like you know very
very much influenced by somebody like
aleister mcintyre in that respect you're
never gonna have some sort of clean pure
metal philosophy wherever it's level
playing field every philosophy actually
is every philosophical um tradition
is already a metaphor because they've
got a notion of what counts this
philosophy of incoherent and why those
other guys over there aren't doing
philosophy
you know um so in some sense there now
should it be
we can ask two questions here
would it be good
for
there to be more interchange
and then should we like you know as
philosophers
as like you know
speaking for other philosophers should
we be pushing that sort of thing
and i would say
uh
yes and then i would leave that up to
the the people that are involved
everybody's you know pretty busy and he
has a lot to do and maybe it's enough to
to do it just in your own practice if
you think it's an important thing to do
or or maybe it's something that we we
should you know try to promote when we
can
um i i would think that one way we can
do it in a very easy way is just through
collegiality
and that seems to be a much we seem to
be in a much better position
with respect to that than say 20 years
ago or 40 years ago
where people were forcing each other out
of departments and you know
you know my mentor
ended up teaching in uh prisons for a
while because there was a a
while where they were trying to phase
out the continental philosophers in siu
and the way they did it was just by
assigning them all prison classes and he
he loved it so it turned out great for
him
i actually taught him prisons too and
very much enjoyed it
he didn't see it as a punishment but it
was intended as a punishment an
inducement to get the hell out of there
i don't see that you know
if we can avoid that sort of stuff and
call other people on it when they're
doing it i think that advances this
mutual understanding but it's very tough
i mean that factor of time we don't have
time enough
to read everybody's stuff
you know even assuming we wanted to and
it's not as if we have a duty a moral
duty to do so i think you know
it's super irrogatory as they say right
i have a question about the time
um
it is uh
couldn't that
give analytic and continental
philosophers
more
more reason not to try to bridge the
divide
if you point out
how little time there is too yeah
and you add in the fact that um
it takes time to write your articles to
get tenure
to make some service make sense of the
other analytics philosophers as it is oh
so that the time would be better spent
understanding the other people just
within your own field
um sort of like you know why should you
you know
look if you if you've already got a
tough family situation you should focus
on devote your activity to that is not
the best analogy but focus your activity
on that don't worry about what's
happening on the other end of town
still sort themselves out maybe after
you get this
taken care of you can go
yeah i guess
one one could say that you know just
with continental philosophy it would be
it would be nice
to have the very
unedifying
activities of mutual you know
recriminations and critiques that go on
just within continental philosophy be a
little bit more
uh respectful and muted
which might be helped by actually
reading each other's works rather than
just saying all those you know
those marxists of those phenomenologists
or whatever
but
yeah i mean
again i don't think anybody has a duty
to learn
from
bridging the gap or anything like that
but it is a good thing
you know
i mean
just as a historian if i had never
read anselm i would have missed out on
so much and that may sound very strange
to some of you
um you know if you maybe just only read
the prosology do you read the the corpus
of his works there's so much rich
thought there
um and uh
you know that was there was a bridging a
gap because nobody was training me to to
re-dance on it was something i had to
decide to do on my own and then i found
people who who on the other side were
supportive of that
the institute for saint anselm studies
for example
and we could come up with lots of
individual examples like that i think
um
it's probably not the best answer but
i think there's another
related need um
my undergraduate degree is in philosophy
but i'm in the grad school for
conventional planning and we talked
about ethics for less than an hour in
one class yeah and so it's i think it's
very necessary somehow to get it into
those participants when i was in yeah
when i was at fayetteville state
university
i got involved in this in co-founding
what we call the ethics and business
education project
one of the reasons we did that was
because they did not have a business
ethics class at all
and they were
being i usually get this acronym mixed
up ascb
uh
they they they belong to that that
organization which is um
sort of an elite thing among business
schools and that organization requires
that for your four-year reaccreditation
you have to demonstrate that you're
actually teaching
uh ethical theories and how to apply
them to your students
so they brought it brought in as
philosophers and they're like hey can
you take a look at our rubrics and maybe
tweak them a little bit and we you know
it was sort of like if you buy a house
and you think that maybe the front door
needs to be fixed and then you find the
frame is messed up and that's nothing
compared to the floor
and the furnace and it just kept getting
bigger and bigger so it turned into a
project and
it was great because you know what we
ended up doing was developing a model
where
the goal was not to have the usual thing
where you bring in the philosophers as
sort of the hired guns to teach the
content on ethics that the business
students uh you know sit through and
then are like fine now we can get to our
real work you know instead it's it's uh
have it be across the curriculum
uh so it's reflected in each class and
business uh textbooks that that have
sections on ethics especially management
sometimes it's crazy stuff you know uh
you take a look at you're like i don't
know where they got these ideas from but
but this is they usually get
utilitarianism right but the other stuff
um it's a little bit
questionable so you want to get that
curriculum
done well and you also want to work with
the educators themselves the business
professors to not to make them experts
in ethics but to bring them to an
intermediary level so that they can talk
about this stuff competently in classes
when their students say well isn't that
all subjective so they know how to
approach those things and it makes such
a huge impact on those students
and we can say similar things for all
sorts of other programs as well
you know where and you know it's
interesting too
from an institutional perspective
um
philosophers there's a total digression
at this point but
this is one of the things i think about
philosophers are one of the best
situated groups
to participate in a whole bunch of
collaborative activities
we are the experts in critical thinking
other people do critical thinking
some of them call things critical
thinking that aren't critical thinking
we are the experts if you look at the
apa delphi report which is the gold
standard and what counts as critical
thinking
um who signed off on it it's mostly
philosophers
we're the ones who teach that we can be
participating by helping the rest of the
curriculum if they want to infuse
critical thinking we can help them do
that ethics we can help them do that as
well and should be doing that
you know um doing just engaging in
practical reasoning on things sometimes
bringing a philosopher in this is one
place too where it probably it's better
to bring in an analytic philosopher than
a continental philosopher
the philosopher asks questions that need
to be asked i was just talking with
joseph about this in in continental
philosophy which often sort of overlaps
with
uh literature or english departments
i i would get into these you know i was
doing continental philosophy for a while
but i was also hanging out with a lot of
english
people
and they would go off and get upset with
me
because um you know
the way people would do things they did
present something and everyone said
that's really cool maybe you know you
could take this a little bit further
there wasn't a lot of critical analysis
a lot of saying i think you got this
wrong and here's why i think you got
this right and so they they would see
the philosophers as being kind of um
boorish
or you know particular or things like
that
but that's a necessary function
that that act you know bringing in a
philosopher will often get you somebody
who can ask the right questions
philosophers want to be involved in
academic administration
philosophers will have to be involved in
whatever you guys have here
that does faculty development
philosophers ought to be involved in
that
philosophers ought to be sitting on a
whole bunch of committees because they
can do so much really good work
as philosophers
but you don't see a lot of that
unfortunately
i think in part because it's not just
because philosophers aren't volunteering
to do it and there's a bit of a push
back
but there's so much potential
for for philosophers
because of the training that we have
to do great work in academic
institutions and in outside institutions
so to make it relevant more specifically
to today
you did mention it in there saying that
the analytics side is probably more
useful for
translating or moving outside of the
discipline specifically into other
disciplines that is that are those
skills going to be more useful
to broaden the
you know the exposure philosophy to
other disciplines
um
are there are the skills of being able
to like ask the right questions you mean
well and being in clarity i suppose
would be helpful for others oh yeah
yeah very much so um pointing out
pointing out when distinctions need to
be made
noting ambiguous terms
um that that often can be helpful um
probably analytics do have an adjunct on
continental philosophers in general with
respect to that i'd say there's certain
certain areas of continental philosophy
where they're very good at doing that
sort of thing hermeneutics you know
um
i'd say historians are really good at
doing that sort of thing as well
um
does that answer your question okay
i gotta cut up a bit on my soap box in
that one
any other questions or
concerns
we need a similar
for the natural sciences
yeah so that's an interesting one um
i don't think an awful lot quite frankly
maybe maybe you know thinking about
conceptions of time
conceptions of matter i'd say you know
there's this new movement of speculative
realism i think it's called
where they're
doing some bridge work between analytic
and continental talking a lot about
ontology and objects and how you might
actually like use heidegger to talk
about
science in any way i think you know
where continental philosophy
has interesting stuff to say about
the application of science
uh is in terms of
you know
societal things organization of
institutions power that's not the
natural sciences themselves
in so far as we're talking about just
the practice of a physicist quad
physicist i don't think continental
philosophy has all that much to offer
there's a whole field of science studies
out there
that gives
you know continental philosophy a
particularly bad name because a lot of
that stuff is just not very good but i
don't even know what it is i can't even
say it's not good work because i
don't think it falls in the category of
work
which i'm sure is going to raise
somebody's objection
um
but you know in terms of how how we
apply
science what we make of the sciences
i think there's
you know
there's useful uh
stuff
the question is whether it's worth the
opportunity cost
that it requires to read through this
dense literature
and um
i don't know
i i suspect not perhaps
yeah so
um
i'm curious as to what you think
analytic philosophy has to offer the
natural sciences and i say this as an
analytic philosopher yeah you know if i
think about what can i say to a
physicist that would help a physicist do
his work yeah nothing
right
well yeah but what can you do i mean
there's there's some questions in the
philosophy of science and i do yeah not
very much a little bit but philosophy of
science is clearly philosophy it's not
doing physics oh yeah yeah you're right
right and what if i got to offer a
physicist or a biologist or any of these
guys in the natural sciences nothing as
far as i can see it's not like they're
itching for philosophers to come in and
help them make distinctions
no they're usually they're usually
telling us how philosophy is no good
and all that sort of stuff yeah um
yeah
you're probably right about that i would
say you know philosophers have a lot to
contribute to
do we want to consider neuro you know
this whole field of neuroscience which
is kind of a hazy field i think at this
point to be a natural science i'd say so
right it seems to be sort of an offshoot
of
biology and i think there's a lot of
conclusion jumping
that goes on in